Walmart plans to automate 65 of its
stores within the next 30 Years in order
to speed up its uh oil e-commerce
fulfillment center the move follows the
announcement of laying off 2000
employees who fulfill online orders
Walmart aims to move around 55 of
packages that it processes through its
fulfillment centers through automated
facilities by January 2026 which is
expected to improve unit cost averages
by about 20 percent the company's
investment in automation technology is
part of it's a more than 15 billion
dollar Capital spending budget this year
this this increased efficiency will
support better inventory management and
Walmart's rapidly grown e-commerce
business Walmart hiked its minimum wage
earlier this year across the country
surpassing 1750 which were expected to
be reflected in March 2nd paychecks Tom
there's a cause and effect here ladies
and gentlemen and so you got Bernie
Sanders out there trying to raise
minimum wage wage minimum wage so how
did Walmart respond first of all they
said for the people that are working
well in our stores that that are doing
well we're going to move you up to 1750
there's it's also a thing about Walmart
was actually paying some education
reimbursements when those people wanted
to go and take some courses but then on
the other side of it the other side of
the board meeting went like this look
uh the stock market is an angry beast
and we gotta feed it and we have to feed
it profits and a thing called the p e
ratio
how much we got
um we got 30 billion dollars in cash
what if we take 15 billion of it and we
invest in automation so we can keep the
best people at 17 bucks an hour but we
can compete with Amazon that's
automating and doing Amazon Prime and
you can click on there and you can get a
tube of toothpaste and an hour to your
front door I don't need instacart Amazon
Prime have you noticed that some things
they'll deliver like in two hours if you
order it now it'll be at your front door
in two hours and there it is and so
they're competing so there's three
angles here the first angle is beware of
capitalists if you put them in the
corner they're going to invent their way
out rule one never screw with real
capitalists and entrepreneurs rule two
you know what if you're gonna force me
to pay people more I only want the best
people and so you better be the best
otherwise you're not gonna be here in
rule three competition brings out an
assortment of things that ultimately are
going to be good to Consumers because
you know what's going to happen here on
one side you could look at Labor and say
oh my gosh my gosh my gosh on the other
side you know what I see I see Walmart
competing with Amazon so that people get
efficient low-cost Consumer Staples at a
time when inflation is up so I look at
the other side and say hey there's going
to be an Amazon and a Walmart competing
so that people on average middle
American incomes can afford to get
things in a base of inflation and I
think that's important but that's what I
see here I see about three things moving
around yeah I'll tell you one thing that
we learned in the last literally a year
maybe two years and when we had Andrew
Yang sitting right here where Vinnie's
sitting right there and this is after
five trillion dollars is printed of
stemi money and he was the biggest
proponent of universal basic income Ubi
that was his whole message uh when he
ran for uh the presidency in 2016. and
um was that was that 2020 whenever he
was running president okay I think it
was 16.
um no 20. and Pat said well make the
case for Ubi now Mr Yang he's like we
just gave out everybody money how we
doing and and you know he kind of
eloquently skirted well you know Ubi
it's just like it doesn't hold water
yeah like this don't work yeah just
printing of the money and giving people
money to sit around and do nothing
doesn't work so uh I guess the point is
companies are gonna have to figure it
out employees are gonna have to figure
it out the the days of maybe Ubi is a
thing maybe just giving stimmy checks is
the thing I think we've proven during
covid this is not going to be beneficial
for the economy
is Walmart bad now or like I like other
robots there when I read automation I go
so wait are ai's taking over our jobs so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]